WE'RE ONLY FIVE MINUTESILL HEADS
GET THE FIRSTHO WINS IT, PUCK
OFF  SHOT BLOCKED,
COLEMAN, HE'LL
SK NICEST STOP SOO HEISKANEN, T,
SLAPS IT UP PLAY.
>> Kelly: S JUST PAST THE THREE
MINUTE MARK OF THE GLOVED ANDISE
BENCH.
PUCK IS O HEISKANEN.
MANGIAPANE, 20 SECONDS LEFT IN
THE POWERPLAY.
NOT DONE SINCE 1990, 91 WITH DÉ.
LAST FOUR GAMES.
STARS HAVE THE GUDBRANSON WILL
T
JOB, GOI GUDBRANSON,
6 1/2 TO GO IN THE S
>> ONE PASS TOO MANY.
JUST A BEAUTIFUL PLAY BY
PETERSON, NOW HE'S GOING TO GETd
OTWO
MINUTES OF THE MIDDLE PERIOD,
SUTER WITH A BANK PASS OUT WINDS
UP OUT OF PLAY.
MATHEMATICALLY,Y
HAVE A CHANCNC YOU'RE RIGHT.
THOUGH, RICK.BODY POSIT WINDS UP
HARD TO TELL.
>> Rick: HERE IS OTHER ATTEMPT,R
SIDE, TANEV, THR 3 1/2 LEFT.
TOP UNIT STARTS, LINDHOLM LINDH,
AND BLOCKED BY OETTINGER.
LINDHOLM CAN'T BEL
NUMBER HANGS
ON.
>> Announcer: THIS PERIOD,
FREE, THROW,
ROBERTSON'S PASS, KLINGBERG JOHE
LINE.